as i've said before
while the present protocol arrangements
remain in place it cannot be business as
usual for north-south relations
this means we must respond not just in
words but in actions as well
we attended the north south ministerial
council plenary meeting in july as an
act of good faith and to give some space
for issues to be resolved
that has not happened
i believe now is the time to act
therefore as the protocol issues remain
unresolved the dup will immediately
withdraw from the structures of strand2
of the belfast agreement relating to
north-south arrangements
while we will ensure that important
health-related matters continue to be
addressed on a cooperative basis
i do so in the full knowledge of the
knock-on effects that such a move may
have
and the instability that may result not
something i want to happen
but we simply cannot go on like this
the threat to the political institutions
is not from our withdrawal from strand2
the threat to the political institutions
is from the protocol itself
the second step i intend to take relates
to the operation of the protocol
that is it has been
to date the full impact of the protocol
has not yet been felt
this is partly because of the grace
periods and partly because the checks
that are required by the protocol are
not being implemented in full
we have not yet experienced the full
impact of the protocol but merely what
some have described as protocol light
but consider even the damage this has
done to our economy and political
stability
i do not pretend that there are easy
answers
when the law requires one thing
and politics demands something else
though some unionists would like to
we cannot wish away the fact that the
northern ireland protocol is part of
domestic law
however i believe that we can use our
position in ministerial office to the
benefit of the people of northern
ireland
no one can be in any doubt that the
ending of the grace periods would have a
devastating impact on northern ireland
that is not something i am prepared to
countenance
or be a party to
nor should any elected politician in
northern ireland who cares for our
people
consider that the ending of the grease
periods is something
to be welcomed
therefore regardless of what the
position is of the uk government or that
of the eu
in the future dup ministers
will seek to block any additional checks
at the ports in northern ireland that
arise from the northern ireland protocol
and i believe they should have a solid
legal basis to do so
any decision to intensify checks would
have the most profound and significant
impact
on northern ireland
under the northern ireland act such a
decision to intensify checks could only
be implemented following a decision of
the northern ireland executive
in such circumstances neither the
agriculture environment and rural
affairs minister my colleague edwin puts
nor his officials have any powers to
intensify checks in the absence of
executive agreement
on behalf of the dup i want to make it
quite clear that dup ministers will use
their votes at the executive to
frustrate any such additional checks now
or in the future
thirdly
we are also examining the legality of
the current checks and whether they
should have required prior executive
approval as well
we are also exploring whether there is
any scope to limit or eradicate the
existing checks at the ports which are
in addition to those which were in force
at the end of 2020
legal advice has offered ministers very
little room for maneuver in this regard
and flexibilities have been exploited
already to the maximum
however
we are seeking to revisit this issue to
examine every available option to to
frustrate
the imposition of these unnecessary
checks on goods traveling from great
britain to northern ireland
in the final analysis those who are
democratically elected by the people of
northern ireland lack the power to
prevent such checks if that is the case
if our ministers cannot in the end
prevent these checks taking place
and if the protocol issues remain
then i have to be clear
the position in office of dup ministers
would become untenable
if the choice is ultimately between
remaining in office or implementing the
protocol in its present form
then the only option
the only option for any unionist
minister
would be to cease to hold such office
this is particularly the case in
circumstances where the government is
proceeding to implement the new decade
new approach agreement in a partial and
one-sided way by legislating for a
culture package at westminster at a time
when the government has not delivered on
its pledge within the new decade new
approach agreement in relation to
restoring northern ireland's place in
the uk
single market
this is not i repeat not a sustainable
position
within weeks it will become clear if
there is a basis for the assembly and
executive to continue in this current
band deal and i want that to happen
but equally
we will also need to consider whether
there is a need for an assembly election
to refresh our mandate if action is not
taken to address and resolve the issues
related to the protocol and its impact
its damaging impact on northern ireland
each and every day
fourthly and finally
in order to maintain the adherence of
northern ireland to eu law as it evolves
there is a requirement for northern
ireland departments and the northern
ireland assembly to pass regulations to
reflect decisions that are taken at an
eu level
it has been said before but it will be
the policy of the dup to seek to
frustrate and to prevent such alignment
we cannot and will not accept a
situation where we are required to
endorse and implement eu laws whilst
having no say whatsoever in how those
laws are formulated
the northern ireland protocol requires
certain aspects of eu law to apply in
northern ireland but this can only
happen if they are incorporated into
northern ireland law
over time a failure to incorporate such
law will mean that northern ireland will
increasingly diverge from eu law and
would ultimately undermine the operation
of the eu single market
as a party we are pledged to make sure
that this happens
we will not support the imposition of eu
laws in northern ireland that have been
formulated without
democratic input from the people of this
part of the united kingdom
once the uk government of course has the
power to introduce such regulations at
westminster
to do so in a blanket fashion i believe
would ultimately
undermine the credibility of the
devolved settlement and that is not
something that we can accept
i've said and i've repeated this morning
that we are totally opposed to the
protocol as it presently exists
we will neither accept it
nor will we work it
in my assessment the time frame for
resolving issues can be measured in
weeks
not months or years
as i've also said doing nothing is not a
sustainable or attainable position
there will be those who will be critical
of these announcements today
but i need to be clear
i take these actions not to undermine
our carefully balanced constitutional
arrangements
but to protect them
in july the government took what might
have been the first step out of the
protocol with the command paper
but it will ultimately be judged by what
it does next
it would be a tragedy if the gains of
the last two decades were put at risk
and if northern arm was plunged back
into economic difficulties and political
crisis
this would not be good for unionism or
good for northern ireland
but for our part
we will work to do all in our power
to make sure that this does not happen
in spite of all the difficulties that we
face i remain hopeful that we can still
emerge from this period with
arrangements which can command
widespread support within northern
ireland arrangements that do not offend
unionists nationalists or others and
crucially arrangements which will allow
us to create the kind of stability that
will be good for investment and economic
prosperity
the prize of a successful outcome is not
just for unionism but for all of
northern ireland and it is not just for
the uk but for the eu as well
just imagine how a new deal which
satisfies all sides could transform
relationships within northern ireland
and with the european union
or what a deal that genuinely
represented a better way forward would
mean for our potential
and our future
think how a stable long-term deal could
allow us to plan for the future and how
it could allow the uk to rebuild its
crucial relationship with the european
union in a challenging and dangerous
world
it surely cannot be beyond us to reach
an agreement that can allow progress to
be made and our peace process to be
secured
i will not be found wanting to do all in
my power to ensure that we can reach
solutions to the problems that we face
but nor should there be any doubt
that i will not resign
from the actions that i have set out
before you this morning
thank you
[Applause]
you